à 20h20 tous les jours il sera avec nous
c'est patrick chan frais pour le jt a
pas hésité c'est parti
[Applaudissements]
merci d'être l'attraction frais pierre
palmade bon soit-il
bonsoir batterie les bases américaines
très bon et vous excessivement bien
merci
j'ai fait des concours de chifoumi avec
ma belle soeur ah oui mais j'ai perdu
moi j'étais un pierre palmade feuille
ciseaux c'est pas vrai vous voulez jouer
m'a dit t'es con merci à l'épaule de
cannes effectivement on démarre tout de
suite par news de type politique le
ministre de l'intérieur gérald darmanin
a déclaré sur bfm ce matin avoir comme
deuxième prénom moussa suite à cette
déclaration le ministre a souhaité par
un retour aux sources en visitant
l'école de sa jeunesse où là bas c'était
un secret pour personne
[Applaudissements]
très bien vu ça il a dû aller sinon
c'est après tracé en la science c'est
super c'est bien sympa il est bizarre
qu'un petit jingle que j'avais décidé de
bosser avec ce qui se passe
la science les astronomes ont pu en
tissage pardon qui ça les astronomes
comme des dates rhône hommes mais mal
dit alors que les astronomes ont pu
observer samedi soir vers 22h30 6
l'explosion d'une planète dû à une
collision avec une météorite nommé
grisou les images
[Musique]
t
[Applaudissements]
on a gagné 1 0 c'est essentiel et
j'embrasse antoine mon ami pierre moi
aussi célèbre et j'adore ses plus belles
coiffures oui mais cultivant en tout cas
ce penalty n'a pas cassé l'ambiance à
mesa pas caser ambiance si un petit peu
près verra plus tard
dans les vestiaires puisque le sponsor a
fourni les boissons pour fêter la
victoire malheureusement ils n'ont pas
fourni le décapsuleur heureusement
didier deschamps avait la solution il
sacré des débats allaient pas s'en
passer
oui une rubrique qui paul le couple kim
kardashian et kanye west sont en plein
divorce apparemment la séparation des
biens se fait à 50/50 visiblement kim
c'est parti avec tous les fronts c'est
là dit il l'a dit c'est la mode la mode
- le lundi vous le savez c'est la mode
la mode la mode
je me tiens c'est quoi c'est la mode
alors oui je suis blessé j'ai très vite
et la modernité des [ __ ] non non non sa
situation de cash game à dire je
voudrais une annonce à la banquière ça
n'a rien à voir
ah oui la mode à ce qu'il fait ça pour
tout un regard des talents et d'affaires
télé un sujet télé télé voilà il ya des
gens de la mode qui font de la télé
pour tous la grande braderie de 4 cette
émission la braderie de lille ayant été
annulé ouais pour cause de coronavirus
les commerçants lillois ont tout de même
décidé d'organiser une braderie version
coheed jean michel mr adeptes de fourtou
et - kerbrat toujours s'est rendu et
apparemment il serait pas entré les
mains vides le salon
[Applaudissements]